egypt
land of the pyramids and pharaohs
one of the most studied and scrutinized
civilizations of the ancient world
and yet it remains veiled in mystery
in this video we are going to see that
the quran reveals secrets about egypt
that until recently were lost to mankind
pharaoh was a tyrant in egypt enslaving
and persecuting the children of israel
the quran states the following about the
death of pharaoh and his supporters
note the words heaven and earth wept not
for them
a recently unearthed pyramid text has
granted us new insights
into the meaning of this verse the
pyramid text reads
the sky weeps for you the earth weeps
for you
when you ascend to heaven as a star
here the pyramid text praises pharaoh
claiming that upon his death he will
ascend through the sky
and claim supremacy of the heavens by
becoming a star
we can see that the quran quotes the
pyramid text directly in its rebuttal of
egyptian adulations of pharaoh
what's amazing is that knowledge of the
ancient
egyptian language of hieroglyphics was
lost to mankind
at the time the quran was revealed it
wasn't until the discovery
of an artifact known as the rosetta
stone in the 18th century
over a thousand years after the
revelation of the quran
that mankind has been able to fully
decode the hieroglyphics
when you hear the word pharaoh what
comes into your mind
most people think of the supreme ruler
of egypt
this is correct but the word did not
always refer to the supreme ruler
ancient egyptian history is divided into
different periods
the word pharaoh egyptian pera
had different meanings depending on the
period of egyptian history
historically the word pharaoh only
started being used as a title for the
supreme ruler
much later in egyptian history during
the new kingdom period
before this the word meant great house
and was used to refer to the royal
palace
the encyclopedia britannica states
pharaoh
originally the royal palace in ancient
egypt
the word came to be used for the
egyptian king under the new kingdom
let's now analyze the quran's accounts
about egypt
in light of these historical facts like
the bible
the quran discusses the prophets joseph
and moses
who both spent time in egypt joseph is
dated by scholars
to either the middle kingdom or second
intermediate period
well before pharaoh meant ruler in the
story of joseph
the quran repeatedly uses the word king
to refer to the ruler of egypt
he is never once called pharaoh
moses is dated by scholars to the new
kingdom period
in the story of moses the quran
repeatedly calls the ruler pharaoh
he is never called king we can see
that the quran is accurate in its use of
language when it comes to describing the
leader of egypt
at different periods in its history how
could the author of the quran have known
this
the only source of information about
ancient egypt
that would have been readily available
are the bible-based stories
to claim that the quran copied from the
bible is problematic
because the bible uses the word pharaoh
to refer to the egyptian ruler in the
story of joseph
which is historically inaccurate the
quran
cannot have copied from the bible
because the quran corrects the bible
[Music]
the bible explicitly states that at the
time of the exodus
the israelites men were vast in number
the israelites journeyed from ramesses
to sukhov
there were about six hundred thousand
men on foot
besides women and children if we factor
in
the women and children then the total
number of israelites would realistically
be in the millions
this claim of a vast nation is
problematic in light of other
information
that the bible provides firstly
pharaoh is said to have appointed two
midwives to deliver
and murder israelite babies
the king of egypt said to the hebrew
midwives whose names were shipra
and pua when you are helping the hebrew
women during childbirth on the delivery
stool
if you see that the baby is a boy kill
him
two midwives would only be sufficient
for such a task
if the israelites were small in number
and giving birth to a manageable
number of babies two midwives would not
be sufficient for a vast nation
of millions
[Music]
secondly the bible tells us that after
the exodus
god informed israel that they would not
be granted the land of their enemies
straight away
but i will not drive them out in a
single year
because the land would become desolate
and the wild animals
too numerous for you little by little i
will drive them out before you
until you have increased enough to take
possession of the land
note the reason for the israelites being
denied immediate possession of the land
it is said that wild animals will
overpower them
such a statement only makes sense if the
israelites were small in number
and not a vast nation of millions as the
bible claims
by contrast the quran states that the
israelites
were only a small band at the time of
moses
we can see that the quran fixes the
contradictions
that are present in the biblical
narrative
the quran states that the punishment of
crucifixion
was used in ancient egypt from the time
of moses
all the way back to the time of joseph
now the word crucifixion typically
brings to mind the roman cross
however in antiquity there were
different forms of crucifixion
professor of archaeology david chapman
wrote
in studying the ancient world the
scholar is wise
not to differentiate too rigidly the
categories of crucifixion
impalement and suspension hence any
study of crucifixion conceptions
in antiquity must grapple with the
broader context
of the wide variety of penal suspension
of human beings
the arabic words translated as crucified
in the quranic verses
all contain the root word solab
arabic dictionaries state that this root
carries a number of meanings
including to harden or stiffen and to
extract oily matter from bones
this word does not only mean death by
being hung
on a roman cross rather it indicates
any method of execution which makes the
body hardened or stiffened and results
in the leaking of bodily fluids
so impalement suspension and the roman
cross
are all included without making any
distinction
archaeological evidence shows that the
ancient egyptians
used to crucify people by impalement on
a stake
the following entry is taken from an
egyptian german dictionary of
hieroglyphics
not the hieroglyph which depicts an
impaled man
this is a punishment that was used
throughout the different periods of
ancient egypt
the abbot papyrus is dated to the new
kingdom period
it mentions an oath that includes
impalement
he took an oath on pain of being beaten
and of being impaled
the earliest evidence for crucifixion by
impalement
is papyrus bulac 18 which is dated to
the early second
intermediate period it states a
bloodbath had occurred with wood
the comrade was put on the stake
we can see that crucifixion by
impalement on a stake
was carried out during the new kingdom
period and at least as far back as the
second
intermediate period these time periods
cover both moses and joseph
which shows that the quran is
historically accurate
as well as mentioning crucifixion the
quran also narrates the following threat
of mutilation
made by the pharaoh of moses
historically we know that capital
punishment in ancient egypt became more
severe
with the advent of the new kingdom
period which is the time of moses
in fact the specific punishment of
mutilation
is primarily associated with the new
kingdom period
for example the turin judicial papyrus
records
persons to whom was done punishment by
severing their nose and ears
on account of them ignoring the good
instruction said to them
these details about crucifixion and
mutilation are missing in the bible
there is a jewish commentary the midrash
shemot rabbah
which mentions pharaoh threatening moses
with burning and crucifixion
but this is a much later work that was
composed centuries after the quran was
revealed
[Music]
neither the bible nor quran identifies
the pharaoh of moses by name
we can use the details provided in the
scriptures
to try to identify the pharaoh
both scriptures speak of the israelites
being taken into slavery
before the birth of moses the use of
semites for slave labor occurred only
during the new kingdom period
so we can place moses somewhere in the
new kingdom period
this gives us a list of 33 possible
pharaohs
both scriptures also speak of an exodus
of the israelites out of egypt
the moneptustele is an important
artifact
that contains the first explicit
reference to israel in the
archaeological record
it is dated to around 1208 bce
it discusses the land of canaan and
mentions the israelites in relation to
kanan
indicating that the exodus had already
taken place by this date
the artifact is contemporaneous to the
pharaoh minepta
this means that the exodus had to take
place before manipta
since monepta was alive and in power
after the exodus and not drowned in the
sea
this establishes an upper boundary in
the timeline of the pharaohs
from the point of view of both the bible
and quran we are now left with
18 pharaohs as candidates who may have
ruled during the time of moses
let's now delve deeper into the biblical
narrative
the bible claims that there were two
different pharaohs who were in power
the first died while moses was in hiding
in midian
when pharaoh heard of this he tried to
kill moses
but moses fled from pharaoh and went to
live in midian
during that long period the king of
egypt died
the new pharaoh continued his
predecessor's persecution of the
israelites
and it was the second pharaoh who was
later drowned when moses crossed the sea
the bible gives us a timeline for these
events
the burning bush encounter with god took
place when moses was 80 years old
so from his birth to the exodus there
was a span of at least
80 years during which two pharaohs ruled
egypt
now there is a big problem if we compare
this biblical narrative
to the timeline of the pharaohs we've
seen that the bible claims
exactly two pharaohs ruled during the 80
year period
from the birth of moses to the exodus
if we consider the number of years that
each of the pharaohs ruled
we can see that there is no 80 year
period
during which only two pharaohs ruled any
given
80-year period will give you at least
three pharaohs in power
we can see that the biblical narrative
contradicts the historical evidence
let's now compare the quranic narrative
unlike the bible the quran depicts a
single pharaoh
reigning from the birth of moses all the
way up to the exodus
the quran informs us that moses fled to
midian
when he reached the age of maturity the
quran defines the age of maturity
as 40 years old the quran also
informs us that during his time in
midian
moses spent eight to ten years in the
service of his father-in-law
before returning to egypt to face
pharaoh
this means that moses was at least 48
years of
age when the exodus happened the only
pharaoh during the new kingdom period
who had such a lengthy reign as an
absolute ruler
was ramesses ii who ruled for 66 years
the quranic account is perfectly in line
with historical evidence
and fixes the chronological issues that
are present in the biblical narrative
[Music]
let's now compare the life and religion
of ramacist ii
to the claims that the quran makes about
the pharaoh of moses
this claim that the pharaoh of moses was
extravagant
has been proven by archaeological
discoveries which show that ramesses ii
was the grandest of the pharaohs the
archaeologist
peter clayton wrote his genuine building
achievements are on a herculean scale
the archaeologist eric uphill wrote the
palace of ramesses
was probably the vastest and most costly
royal residence
ever erected by the hand of man the
egyptologist
kenneth kitchen wrote certainly in his
building works for the gods
ramesses ii surpassed not only the 18th
dynasty
but every other period in egyptian
history with regards to the religion of
the pharaoh of moses
the quran makes the following claim
the quran states that the pharaoh of
moses was arrogant
exalting himself to the position of god
modern archaeological discoveries have
proven this to be true
ramesses ii built the great temple at
abu simbel
to honor himself its entrance is flanked
by four colossal statues of ramesis the
second
which dwarf the statue of ra harakhti
god of the horizon located above it this
temple also contains an image of
ramacist ii
making a sacrifice to his divine self
the quran makes the following claim
about the pharaoh of moses
who god drowned in the sea
we can see that the quran explicitly
states that the pharaoh's body will be
preserved as a sign for future
generations
note that the quran never makes such a
statement about any of the other
destroyed nations that it discusses
typically stating that their abandoned
buildings and ruins
have been made signs for later
generations
this claim about a body being preserved
is unique to the pharaoh of moses
the body of ramacist ii was discovered
by archaeologists
in the year 1881 ce the mummy
has been on display in the cairo museum
and over the last century
it has been seen by millions of tourists
from all over the world
in the following documentary sir tony
robinson states
that ramesses ii is one of the few
pharaohs whose body has survived largely
intact
just across the river from luxor lies
the famous valley of the kings
where ramesses himself was buried
his mummy was discovered in 1881
one of the few pharaohs whose body has
survived largely intact
historically priests had concealed his
body in a secret location
in the year 1000 bce because of a
problem
with grave robbers nothing was known
about his mummy
in the intervening period of almost 3
000 years
at the time the quran was revealed the
whereabouts
and fate of pharaoh's body was unknown
during the 3000 year period
in which the body was hidden it could
easily have been damaged or stolen
it may have even remained lost forever
locked away in its secret location
never to be rediscovered if you think
about it
these statements in the quran are not
only historically accurate
but also represent quite a bold prophecy
[Music]
the bible informs us about a series of
plagues
that god brought upon egypt the book of
exodus informs us
that the first six of these plagues are
as follows
first the nile was turned into blood
second masses of frogs third
swarms of mosquitoes fourth
swarms of flies fifth
the death of livestock sixth
boils on people and animals now at first
glance
this series of plagues in the biblical
narrative may seem random and unrelated
however the quran sheds light on these
events the quran states the following
about the divine punishments against
egypt
[Music]
notice the first punishment mentioned by
the quran a flood
this is an important detail that is not
found in the bible
this punishment of a flood actually
explains the six
seemingly random and unrelated plagues
in the biblical narrative
a flood would result in high
concentrations of red earth
entering the nile river and causing a
bloodlike colour
killing fish and making the water
undrinkable
as described in the biblical narrative
this phenomenon
is attested to historically as recorded
by a middle kingdom egyptian sage
see the river is blood one shrinks from
other people
and thirsts for water the rest of the
biblical plagues
are also easily explained as a
consequence of the flood
frogs mentioned in plague number two are
known to fill the land
after nile floods the death of the frogs
recorded in the biblical narrative can
be caused by contamination of anthrax
that was carried over from the rotting
fish mosquitoes
mentioned in plague number three
proliferate after nile floods
as the pools of water left over from the
flooding
would have allowed them to overbreed
swarms of flies
mentioned in plague number four will be
brought about by the massive death of
frogs on the land
the death of pasturing livestock
mentioned in plague number five
can be explained by anthrax as brought
on the land by the frogs
the boils on humans and cattle mentioned
in plague number six
may have been caused by bites the stable
fly in particular
is infamous for its vicious biting of
mammals
we can see that the quran's mention of a
flood
easily explains the biblical plagues
which are not random
as initially appears to be the case but
in fact a series of interrelated events
the quran mentions the following
incident about joseph while he was in
egypt
here the quran states that joseph was
sold for a poultry price
the arabic phrase used is
which contains the words dirham and ma
dude
dirham means a unit of silver coinage or
weight
ma dude means countable or limited in
number
so the quran is making the claim that
joseph was sold
for a small amount of countable silver
there is plenty of historical evidence
that standardized units of silver were
used in transactions in
ancient egypt small pieces of silver
known as shati were used in trade
the tomb of nyanknom and konam hotep
is dated to the old kingdom period it
contains a scene
of a busy open-air market with goods for
sale
cubits of cloth for example are said to
be sold
for six chatty the ringed mathematical
papyrus
is dated to the second intermediate
period it discusses
the relative values of gold silver and
lead
in terms of shatty small silver bars
bearing the name of pharaoh tutankhamun
have been dated to the new kingdom
period
they are inscribed with a hieroglyphic
which states
tutankhamun ruler of heliopolis in upper
egypt
until recently historians believed
that the minting of precious metals was
a later greek invention
these recent egyptian archaeological
discoveries
have forced historians to completely
revise
their understanding of coinage in the
ancient world
how is it possible that such knowledge
was revealed in the quran
nearly one and a half thousand years ago
the bible mentions that joseph was sold
for 20 of silver however this sale
is said to have taken place with some
arabs outside egypt
by contrast the quran states that the
sale took place
inside egypt so the bible could not have
been used as a source by the quran
it is in fact the bible that contains
historical errors when it comes to
coinage
for example the bible makes the claim
that a gold coin
known as the darrick was used at the
time of king david
they gave toward the work on the temple
of god five thousand talents
and ten thousand derek's of gold
as historians point out that derek is
named
after the persian leader darius the
great who lived hundreds of years after
king david
the jewish encyclopedia acknowledges
this error
a notable instance of anachronism occurs
in first chronicles
29 7. gold daryks
coins which were not struck before the
time of king darius the first
i.e more than 400 years after david
[Music]
the quran narrates the following
conversation between the pharaoh of
moses
and an individual referred to as hamad
to build a tower that would allow him to
reach the heavens
it's important to understand that
pharaoh's intention
was not to literally scale a tower to
reach the sky
rather it's a reference to the egyptian
belief
that after death the pharaoh would
ascend from earth to heaven
taking his place among the gods as we
covered earlier
the author of the quran had an awareness
of ancient pyramid texts
that detailed such beliefs egyptian
monuments
housed the bodies of dead pharaohs these
acted as a bridge between this world and
the next
they were filled with religious writings
that served as instructions
to help the dead pharaoh ascend to the
heavens hence
the person in charge of constructing
such a monument for pharaoh
would not only need to be skilled in
architecture
but also highly knowledgeable in
religion they build a priest of sorts
let's now turn to history to see if we
can identify
an individual known as harman who was
both a builder
and a priest earlier we concluded that
ramesses ii
was the pharaoh at the time of moses so
we will focus on this time period
a block statue in the egyptian museum of
munich
contains a biographical account of the
life of a high priest named
bakken hansu in his own words he states
i am one truly reliable useful to his
lord
who performs beneficent deeds within his
temple
i being principal chief of works in the
estate of armon
i erected obelisks of granite stone
whose tops reached to the sky
here back in hon soo tells us that he
served the pharaoh in two ways
first by performing rituals in the
temple and second
as chief architect in fact
bakken honsu was an architect
extraordinaire
being one of the greatest in all of
ancient egypt
he is responsible for constructing the
temple of amun
at karnak a monument that remains one of
the largest religious structures
ever created by man with regards to the
priesthood
bakken hansu informs us that he had a
very long and illustrious career
i was a third prophet of our moon for 15
years
i was a second prophet of amon for 12
he appointed me high priest of amon for
27 years
here back in khon su is stating that he
served the god amon
throughout his priestly career amun is
the name
of an egyptian deity who rose to
prominence during the new kingdom period
by the time bakken hansu died he had
been a priest
for many decades having served ramesses
ii
as high priest throughout his reign both
ramesses ii
and back in hansu were contemporaries
who died around the same time
what about the quran's mention of harman
how does it relate to back in hansu
back referred to himself by the title
high priest of amun the actual phrase in
the hieroglyphics
is
the word harm literally means servant
and amana is how you articulate the name
of the god amun
in egyptian back in honsu was harm amana
meaning servant of amun the quran's
mention of harman
may be simply an arabised version of the
egyptian
hamamana let's now summarize the main
points about bakken hansu
he was a senior ranking figure under
pharaoh ramesses ii
acting as both high priest and chief
architect he served in the temple of the
god amun
and thus had the title hamamana it is
clear that all of the historical
evidence fits
perfectly with the quranic
now it's important to point out that the
bible also mentions
ahaman but the resemblance is only in
name
the biblical harmon served under a
persian king
and bears no relation to the quranic
harman of egypt
yet again these are details that are
completely missing in the biblical
narrative
in this video we have seen that the
quran has a remarkable insight
into many facets of ancient egypt
revealing long lost knowledge
while also correcting the bible claims
that the author of the quran
copied from the bible are clearly
rubbished in light of such facts
the quran boldly declares its origins
to learn more about the miracles of the
quran please download your free copy of
the book
the eternal challenge at the link below